le télétravail toujours encouragé donc
par le gouvernement malgré l'accalmie
sur le front du coc vide
le nouveau protocole sanitaire en
entreprise qui s'applique dès
aujourd'hui ne change pas la donne
télétravail et pour limiter les
contaminations kobe doit rester la norme
pour les salariés qui le peuvent alors
quel bilan peut-on tirer de cette
nouvelle façon de travailler qui s'est
imposé avec la pandémie est ce un
progrès ou au contraire une régression
pour celles et ceux qui ont dû s'y
mettre c'est notre rubrique l'édito avec
jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques la question donc du
télétravail qui a été au centre des
différends confinement que l'on a connu
sommes nous au début d'une nouvelle ère
où tout cela n'aura été qu'une grande
illusion finalement bonsoir c'est fini
alors oui effectivement le gouvernement
aimerait bien que le télétravail se
perpétue d'abord évidemment pour des
raisons sanitaires et puis aussi parce
que ça conforte d'une certaine manière
son image de la start up nation
après il est clair que les entreprises
l'année dernière avait vu ce
développement du télétravail avec un
certain optimisme
et elle avait même commencé à réduire
assez fortement la superficie des
bureaux qu'elle avait où qu elles louées
et puis est venu le retour du bâton et
est venu le lui dire elle à la prise en
compte du fait que le bilan du
télétravail apparaît comme beaucoup plus
nuancé voire carrément négatif pour les
salariés mais aussi pour les entreprises
alors tout d'abord jacques combien ne
salariés sont ils passés au télétravail
alors lors du premier confinement vous
savez le confinement de la fin mars 2020
jusqu'au début mais on estimé qu'il y
avait
et en moyenne environ 25% de l'ensemble
des salariés
c'est extrêmement important qui était
passé en travaillant télétravail tota
probablement 30 % si on regarde le
télétravail partiel et même 40%
si on considère les gens qui allaient
qui était au télétravail un jour par
semaine voire qui avait travaillé
quelques jours dans le mois
en télétravail ce chiffre retombe autour
de 10% de l'ensemble des salariés à
l'été 2020 puis avec le 2ème et le 3ème
confinement il remonte mais à 20% sert
pas du tout au niveau auquel il était en
mars mars avril 2020 et aujourd'hui on
est en train d'assister à un espèce de
d'effondrement du télétravail et qu'est
ce qui explique ces chiffres alors il y
as derrière ces chiffres
toute une série de raisons la première
chose qui est importante à comprendre
c'est que la crise sanitaire a entraîné
très souvent une dégradation des
conditions de travail ou en tous les cas
une intensification des conditions de
travail
avec ça il y a évidemment la mise en
place du télétravail pour les
travailleurs et qui pouvait le faire et
là on se rend compte que cette mise en
place du télétravail
d'une certaine manière accentue c'est ce
sentiment si vous voulez d'une
intensification ou d'une dégradation
et puis surtout que si vous voulez ce
télétravail
eh bien il va entraîner une forte montée
des objectifs chiffrés des exigences
émotionnelles et puis de l'intensité de
la durée du travail
beaucoup de gens se plaignent
effectivement du fait que le télétravail
abouti à des horaires complètement
chamboulé ils sont obligés de travailler
le soir ou de travailler très tôt le
matin
donc tout cela constitue je dirais une
espèce de base de fond de la situation
des télétravailleurs
mais jacky y at-il eu des différences
notables entre les télétravailleurs et
les autres oui tout à fait tout à fait
alors on voit que 56% des gens qui sont
au télétravail disent que leur situation
a changé et c'est s'est plutôt dégradée
dans la période de la crise sanitaire
contre 44% pour les gens qui ne sont pas
en télétravail est par ailleurs au sein
des télétravailleurs donc là on ne
regarde que les gens qui sont en
télétravail et bien ces 33% qui
considère qu' il ya une intensification
du travail et 14% qui considère qu'il ya
une dégradation des situations de
travail
par ailleurs il est clair que ceci a
entraîné un accroissement des inégalités
on voit très bien que ce sont les gens
qui hervé les cons les compétences les
plus faibles ou petits d'une certaine
manière et et je dirais le moins
appareiller pour faire du télétravail
qui se plaignent le plus mais il ya
aussi les femmes qui se plaignent le
plus et ça c'est un point important
parce que ça met le doigt sur les
conditions de travail
comprenez bien que télétravail et quand
on a des enfants à la maison quand on
doit garder justement ces enfants à la
maison
et bien c'est quelque chose qui est pas
du tout évident jacques à quoi est venue
alors il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
phénomènes ya tout d'abord la question
de la maîtrise des instruments
numériques
le fait que évidemment toute une série
de gens qui ont été obligés de passer au
télétravail avait une maîtrise moyenne
ou ou relativement faire il ya aussi le
fait que les connexions ou disons la
partie technique du système n'était pas
au point
alors que ce soit évidemment la vitesse
de transfert
la nature des ordinateurs donc on
pouvait disposer à la maison qui sont
souvent d'eux
de moindre qualité que ce que l'on
pouvait avoir au bureau il ya aussi les
conditions générales de travail vous
savez ce n'est pas simple de transférer
un bureau chez soi alors c'est la
question de la superficie la question
des conditions de logement est ce que la
personne vit seule
ou est ce qu'elle vit en couple est ce
qu'elle vit sans enfant ou est ce
qu'elle vit avec des enfants bon c'est
l'ensemble de ces problèmes qui sont
venus pour constituer je dirais un
espèce de ressenti assez important du
fait que le télétravail entraîne une
dégradation de la situation de travail
oui la question qu'on peut se poser ce
que c'est lié à la durée du télétravail
ce oui oui on voit très bien que dans
les réponses à lenquête tracks of café
la dares et bien il y à une montée de ce
genre de problème avec si vous voulez la
durée l'enquète tracks of isole par
exemple des gens qui n'ont jamais été
les travailler des gens qui ont
travaillé un ou deux jours par mois
un jour par semaine donc et on voit que
c'est à partir de 3-4 jours par semaine
que les problèmes se posent en
particulier sur les questions de santé
on voit qui a très bien une espèce de
monter de la perception de douleur
physique par exemple le mal de dos et si
vous voulez quand on quand on est comme
ça courbet face à un ordinateur ou des
troubles du sommeil qui représente
aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez
important d'ailleurs les troubles du
sommeil dans la population qui travaille
trois à quatre jours par semaine
c'est le double de la proportion dans la
population qui ne travaillent jamais en
télétravail
cela veut donc dire que le télétravail
il ya eu des conséquences
carrément néfastes pour la santé oui
tout à fait et ça ça on peut le dire
alors il ya évidemment ces questions de
douleurs aux trains de douleurs
physiques ces questions de perturbation
du sommeil et alors ça touche évidemment
les gens qui se plaignent le plus de
l'intensification ou de la dégradation
comme on le voit sur le graphique
mais il ya aussi d'autres phénomènes ne
fait que les gens et qu'ils avaient des
compétences moyenne sont les premiers à
se plaindre du fait qu'ils avaient peu
de soutien que ce soit de leur
hiérarchie ou de leurs collègues et ça
c'est aussi visiblement un ressenti qui
a été très fort la sensation d'isolement
dans le télétravail
en conclusion jacques le télétravail est
il un échec une voie sans issue
alors on peut peut-être pas parler
d'échec ou de voie sans issue comme tel
mais il est clair que le télétravail a
posé énormément de problèmes et je crois
qu'il faut distinguer deux situations
d'abord il ya des gens qui ont de très
fortes compétences qui ont d'une
certaine manière déjà l'habitude de se
servir des instruments numériques aussi
des gens qui sont dans de très bonnes
situations qui ont des grands
appartements qu'ils peuvent se permettre
de faire garder leurs enfants ou qui
n'ont pas d'enfant par ailleurs alors
ces gens là qui représente grosso modo
10 à 15 % des gens qui sont passés en
télétravail
autrement dit entre 1 et 1 et demi pour
cent entre 3 et 4 et demi pour s'en
excuser moi de l'ensemble des salariés
français
ces gens là ont plutôt apprécié le
télétravail mais pour le reste eh bien
on voit bien qu'il y a eu un sentiment
de dégradation et d'intensification un
sentiment aussi d'isolement de perte de
repères face à l'ensemble du collectif
de travail qui existait auparavant
au point que le retour au bureau qui a
été possible
depuis maintenant quelques semaines et
bien ce retour au bureau il est très
souvent vécue comme un soulagement voire
même comme une libération
par seth et les travailleurs
et voilà qui donne donc à réfléchir
parfois qu'on pays des d'ailleurs
préconçues merci et jacques et à la
semaine prochaine